well
and uh magnus ended up playing nine
which is quite a lot but uh yeah prank
he was playing as many games as possible
and
he finally makes his first move ten
minutes delayed but here we go the ftx
crypto cup has started and we have the
first move from pragnanda we have the
first move and not the move we predicted
according to the stats we thought he'd
open with his queen's pawn play one d4
instead it's a king's pawn opening and
the spanish one of the oldest openings
in chess
oh the berlin defense though simon are
you happy to see that the most solid
opening for black out there no
it goes against my prediction as well
you know i thought that there would be
fire on the board and well we have
something very solid
so it's a variation of the berlin
defense and this is known as a very safe
variation for both colors look at the
pawn structure it's completely
symmetrical right now it's level
material as well white temporarily
sacrificed a pawn but won it back and
now with this developing move white
wants to gain something using his first
move advantage he wants to jump into the
center with this knight and potentially
win the bishop pair
so um it's just playing for tiny tiny
incremental advantages in this type of
position this is a very typical night
retreat black's knight was actually in
the way of some of his pawns so the
black knight jumps back maybe we'll
reroute itself later and there we go the
white knight attacks the black bishop
the bishop moves attacking the white
rook and we'll see a bit of a dance
between this white knight and black star
squad bishop
but this is all well-known stuff yeah i
can actually remember the la the last
tour we were commentating on i was
sitting here and i think we saw exactly
the same thing uh occur and i also
nearly fell asleep in that game so i'm
joking joking it's really exciting stuff
fascinating all the pieces on the board
it's just i always joke about the berlin
because it's got this reputation of
being um quite dull which i think is
actually quite unfair and we joke about
it um kasparov said the even the the
queenless middle game is one of the most
exciting middle games you can get but we
look here it's just the symmetrical
nature of the pawns uh and it does often
lead to draws doesn't it to be fair it's
it's a safe way to play yeah from both
players i think and you've got a good
memory there simon because the game
you're referring to is actually anish
geary against
and that ended in surprise surprise can
you predict the result let's go for
a draw oh yes wow
or i'm good
the reason it has such a drawish
reputation this type of opening is that
the pawn structure is
almost completely symmetrical you won't
see any pawn trades any open lines any
attack on either sides kings both kings
super safe if anything we'll just see a
bunch of trades the vacuum cleaner will
come out hoover off all the pieces
and uh interesting strategy from prague
especially i can understand why faroush
is doing this uh he's just kind of
feeling his way in with black you just
want to be solid you don't want to lose
the first game but for prague in such
good form why not play something a bit
more aggressive and now the bishops have
come off that's one check with the white
knight but it's just one check nothing
more
and
zero problems at all for black
i'm also very surprised that he didn't
start with d4
i think as ivanka said you know that's
his normal move
you've always the problem when you play
e4 nowadays you've always got to expect
the berlin at top level because it's
well known that
it's probably like equal no one has
really proven
any way to get an edge or even like an
interesting ish position really i mean
okay you've got the bishop advantage
here is that really enough to win i
i mean i it shouldn't be should it i
would say he's playing very quickly so
this does suggest some kind of
preparation that he's found a way to
maybe apply some tiny pressure on the
black position
but he has to do it now because if he
doesn't then nighttime says then black
is simply going to develop the knight
connect the rook start challenging for
the open line and uh what do you think
about this porn move that's uh appeared
on the board
it makes some sense i guess because you
have the bishop versus knight here and
that's the only imbalance white bishop
looks pretty sad right now let's be
honest you have to open up lines you
have to hope that there'll be some pawn
trades you'll get some open files for
your rooks open diagonals for the white
bishop
but then again
the white pawns in the center they are
not light squares so if things do get
blocked up or
even if we do see one set of pawn
exchanges white's bishop still struggles
to get in the game
you're right you've anchored there must
be some idea behind it it must be very
deeply studied with the computer maybe
prague and his coach they've decided
let's not take too much risk in the
first game with white ferrugia after all
does like dynamic attacking chess why
not just bore him to death
that's the strategy i try and use all
the time i'll tell you what i hate it
when players do that against me
i mean i would never dare say that
you've ever done that against me david
but
but you have it yeah and it always works
so um but it's a good strategy against
uh frugia right a very good strategy
so maybe he's planning playing the man
not necessarily just the board he's
trying to get inside his opponent's head
trying to figure out his opponent's
strengths and weaknesses and
okay black's knight comes to a very safe
square black's pieces look great to be
honest but uh at least white's queen can
maybe head out towards the left side of
the board start attacking some pawns
over there which don't have too many
defenders
very early days but uh
yeah what can we say it's slow and
steady this
and steady start to uh the fdx crypto
cup and we have to mention something so
there is an ftx crypto cup
fantasy challenge and if you want to
join that fantasy challenge you have to
do it today so what you do is you claim
you're free ftx cryptokey and uh
on discord you can join the uh challenge
the fdx crypto cup fantasy challenge you
basically choose who you think will win
the fdx crypto cup and
the price fund is 15 000
so
let's say magnus carlsen wins then
everyone who picked magnus carlsen as
the winner will share fifteen thousand
dollars so you know this is a strategy
question should you for example
answer hans niemann and if he ends up
winning well maybe a big bunch of that
money will go to you what will you guys
do in this situation i wouldn't bet on
hands
just being honest i mean he's a great
player but he is still you know he's not
quite up there with the level of the
other players um 15 000 though that's
that's some serious cash that anyone can
win that money right so anyway it splits
between everyone who yeah picks the
correct winner pick hands yeah
i'm being rude only person picking hands
yeah
take it all for yourself one of the
young players would be a good bet then
maybe hands is a good bet because like
if you share it with everyone who's
voted that's right that's the way it
works so not as many people will vote
for hands as magnus
and um yeah you could probably you could
probably win at least seven and a half
thousand if fans win
pretty good
um but no i mean i i i love your hands
um but yeah great great competition to
get into yeah exactly so uh
who have you picked
i picked duda
yeah because you know i think he's a bit
of a dark horse i know he won the oslo
esports cup but after that he hasn't
done so well he didn't do well on
candidates he did really badly in the
olympiad and he didn't only played five
games
but i think you know
the luck has to turn yeah and i think he
will quietly appear from nowhere just
like he did last time yep and how about
you david strategically who is the best
bet here i'm going for lev on aronian um
i actually on one of the final nights of
the olympiad i was hanging out with
aronian and the american team we were
playing cards and he seemed in good form
he was really looking forward to this
event we saw last month he was on fire
he won and
it's just the speed the confidence i
think he's uh he might sneak it
all right well if you want to join in
the uh ftx fan to see the ftx crypto cup
fantasy challenge then you need to claim
your free
crypto key and if you just use your
phone and scan the
the qr code in the bottom of the screen
well then you can go claim your free
key and if you do
claim your key then a bunch of content a
bunch of cool prices to be given out
a lot of money to be given out uh during
the fdx crypto cup so go ahead and claim
your key now in this game a uh long
pulse now for alireza for
yeah um longer than any of the things
we've seen so far he's spent about two
minutes now and it is a big decision
maybe the first big decision of the game
for him and uh white is attacking a pawn
maybe we can jump in and show the
dilemma now for farouza white's queen is
attacking this pawn on b7 it's
undefended how do you defend it uh if
you push it one square forward suddenly
the integrity of black's pawn structure
is lessened suddenly these pawns are
potentially a bit weak they no longer
fully connect
and uh okay he doesn't defend them at
all i was going to say maybe you could
put your rook to a passive square defend
it from this side or this side just to
keep this pawn under guard but ferugia
says no i'm going to counter-attack and
the other factor here is that black
knight and queen are actually on the
wrong side of the board they want to be
over defending their pawns but by
sneaking his queen forward now
forusia has set the trap that if the
white queen gets greedy takes the spawn
the black knight jumps in and i think
this is just going to end up in
checkmate
the queen is going to take either this
pawn defended by the knight or this pawn
defended by the knight and the white
king no longer has sufficient defenders
and the other idea behind ferocious move
of course is that assuming prague sees
this threat and pushes upon kicks back
the queen now he can put his queen on
the right side of the board he can
defend all of his pawns on this flank
and also control the seventh rank
white's rook wanted to jump in but
black's queen covers everything now so a
bit of a sneaky trap there set by frugia
but with a nice idea behind it he just
wants to drop his queen back and hold
everything together
yeah very nice isn't it using tactics
and attacking possibility just to kind
of secure his position
i like what he's done definitely yeah
the queen was on the wrong side of the
board and getting it back seems seems
correct and well were you both uh
obviously you've been playing the
olympiad you're over there were you
impressed by the indian players i mean i
know the answer to that because
it goes without saying but their
preparation their new ideas this must be
a new idea their teamwork
uh their fans i mean uh
you know it's incredible must be an
incredible experience but there's so
many good young players there's not one
or two there's a there's an army of them
it's incredible
um but it must have been really really
like you know just eye-opening i mean a
great experience at least to be there so
oh absolutely and like you say you know
a lot of them come from the same area as
well from chennai thanks to ramesh's
hard work as a coach and there we see
the porn attack the queen i mean it was
really impressive i mean i also the way
that they approached the games with such
energy
i it was unbelievable i've never seen
so many talented youngsters yeah one
team
yeah yeah i mean and just the ideas i
have in the opening like i know it's the
berlin i know it hasn't got a reputation
but this is an interesting idea right
and just finding these ideas i mean
david if you had a ramesh behind you
you'd be you'd probably be like 29.50 by
now
so we we need to get some get david a
ramesh yeah so can we get david a remote
that is that's the next plan after your
brilliant gold medal supercoach yeah and
uh i mean the one thing that struck me
about these indian talents like pregnant
is they all work together that's the one
big difference that india have kind of
i mean they've just been working
together since the young age this whole
generation they're all between the ages
of 16 and 18 now and they've been
working together for five uh five years
at least all with the same coach they
don't mind sharing opening ideas they
don't mind analyzing together sharing
their own strengths and weaknesses but
they push each other to greater heights
and compared to england where we're from
maybe where we're all lone wolves we all
study separately we all treat each other
as rivals the indians they don't have
that kind of
mindset they just treat each other as
inspira as inspiration
and i know that's the case with prague i
would often walk around the hotel i'd
walk back at 2am and he's just playing
table tennis with his teammates and
just the spirit there that kind of
propelled them that's why they nearly
won the olympiad
and the winning team of course in the
open section uzbekistan they have that
same mentality and the four of their
players are between the ages of 16 and
20 they grew up together they work
together they study together and
folks i thought it was incredible how
they also got you know gifted so much
money uh by by winning um each of the
individual players i i don't know how
much it was but they got something like
sixty thousand dollars and and a car and
so to throw that in there as well
which is maybe well i know uh the guy
who did not do satoru when he uh won the
blitz world championship he got a house
you got a house yeah i mean imagine that
in england
i mean yeah 60 000 is a lot but that's
actually i think over 30 times the
national salary in a year so these guys
they're rock stars now they're
celebrities they're set for life they
can just focus on chess they're just
gonna um the pressure's off them they've
achieved uh a lot already and they're
gonna go on and achieve more i think
india is becca's done and maybe the us
those three are the dominant forces in
terms of the young players coming
through
yeah and uh definitely you know david
spoke about spirit and i also want to
say you know it is miami time and we are
definitely enjoying despite the weather
and
enjoying a great chess spirit and party
spirit and of course we love it i hope
when you're at home share with us all
this excitement and we want to see your
selfies how you're watching the tour as
always you can tweet us using the
hashtag chesschamps and just to kick us
all off abby shack says that he is was a
special day in india they're celebrating
75 days of in 75 years not 75 days of
independence wow and so he's flag
hoisting kite flying and now the ftx
crypto cup on tv this is how india's
75th in the independence day is going to
end for me good luck prague fantastic
congratulations to everyone in on their
uh independence day definitely and uh
the queen has retreated
over to defend the pawn and nima mag
masadagari is watching the crypto cup
from iran and uh cheering for ali reza
faruga yes and uh they're pragananda
playing very quickly again and again
with the
nice kind of ideas you know he moves his
queen attacks the pawn and potentially
supports a rook coming to the seventh
row rooks love being on the seventh
line and uh look at that suddenly it's a
little bit uncomfortable for alireza
yeah you're right you've anchored dual
threat here attacking this pawn of
course which needs to move or be
defended
and okay it doesn't need to be be
defended for russia this is why he's so
good he's full of tricks he pushes his
pawn forward here blocking the white
queen's diagonal so this e7 square is no
longer protected white's rook can no
longer use the square because black's
queen could just capture any piece that
lands there
and also the secondary idea is that if
white's queen gets greedy and grabs a
pawn suddenly her escape route along
this diagonal has been blocked so black
syrup can just move across and trap her
she's lost here she has to give herself
up for just a rook so white's queen
should not get greedy here um in the
current position however maybe one
diagonal has been loosened up white's
bishop at some point will just sit in
front of his king fiance and along this
diagonal a couple of targets a lot of
control so
computer the evaluation bar really likes
white's chances right now i'm not as
convinced as the computer but it looks
like prague has found a way
to at least uh create something yeah
i don't know if there's some tactical
reason normally normally when a computer
jumps like that there's there's
something wrong but
uh i pointing out that bishop the light
squared bishop it does have great range
coming there just positionally that
looks like a good thing but is there
something more more uh
dynamic there yeah quite possibly um
i'm looking maybe
could you make an argument for capturing
a pawn in the center and now putting the
bishop on this square or maybe just
moving your rook across actually
incidentally you know time when you
mention that there's tactics if there
isn't tactics there's actually this
reason
the computer just says this is
positional yeah this is uh going to be
maybe white's winning a pawn because you
continuously yeah you start attacking
the pawn
yeah on the a7 square yeah and of course
the bishop is going to go to a beautiful
diagonal it's quite a
sort of
not the first move you look at pawn
takes pawn because you you kind of ruin
your pawn structure as white but um
you've got a bishop you want to open up
lines so it does does make sense and so
prague's opening idea could could really
be working out here and maybe now is the
only moment i can really profit from
farouz's play because um the move that i
wanted to play initially the move that
i'm attracted to at first just free
encountering this bishop nice square
nice bishop but after a trade of pawns
black can just push his pawn forward to
solidify everything these pawns defend
each other
and maybe there's just no big
breakthrough maybe white's queen now is
a bit misplaced any rooks coming to the
center can now just be challenged and
black doesn't have any target any pawns
that white can target here there are no
weaknesses in black's camp maybe this is
just fine for black um so maybe now it's
just the one moment that prague can
kind of initiate something can create
that it's played it plays it of course
he does i mean
nowadays you don't expect anything less
from prague i mean it's like
you know he's going to play the best
moves i mean i have to admit like you
know a year or two ago
you wouldn't expect it as much he's
improved so much over that period of
time it's like whenever we're
commentating on magnus's games it's like
will he find this ridiculously hard move
of course he'll find it and now prague
of course he'll find it so it's uh you
know he's a little a little magnus on
there i have to i'm coming i have to say
you know when i tuned in to the
commentary done by peter lecker and
peter smith on the olympiad you know
they always happened to be on
pragnando's games and there was that
comment oh is he gonna find it and then
like five minutes later he plays the
best move
they're like of course
[Laughter]
that's how he rolls yeah
and uh meanwhile we do see farouza and
his screen in front of him he was
actually hovering over his knight he was
going to take this ball back immediately
but he stopped he paused for
uh 30 seconds or so just to check what
prague has in mind here i guess we're
all expecting prague's rook in the
corner just to shuffle across that's the
only piece not really doing too much you
could make an argument for white's
bishop kind of moving to attack this
black knight in the center
but why not bring that rook into play
line up your rooks with your opponent's
queens that's always good strategy
and it's very hard to say
save a porn isn't it after that move
because you're threatening to yeah i
mean you just got loads of threats it
could just be very strong has he played
it
will prague find the best move yes he
finds the best move yeah surprise
surprise so yeah
well the bar is now saying 1.2 advantage
for young pragnanda are you still saying
that this is very jewish or could you
see this explode this has opened up
slightly i wouldn't say explode yet but
there's potential there's enough pieces
on the board i think that's the key no
matter what type of opening you choose
whether it's a slow grindy boring type
of opening or well i say boring in honor
of you simon but uh yeah
whether it's that or a really dynamic
aggressive direct opening as long as you
keep enough pieces on the board there's
always life there's always chances
you'll outmaneuver your opponent later
so um yeah i don't think this one's
boring anymore no i mean it looks just
very tricky for black um and maybe again
like i think you're like someone's done
who said it but you're playing the
player not the board as much because you
know that this opening could really
throw
an attacking player off of kilter and it
kind of has because uh farouza played
this this move in the center of the
board uh c5 and it seems like just a bad
move basically
his own position trying to be active
trying to try to come forwards but it's
created a lot of errors do you think
that um farouza is aware because i mean
luckily
well actually to our advantage we can
look at the evaluation bar and we can go
actually you know why it's in a serious
has serious advantage but black on the
other hand
is doing really badly but will he know
because you know
he's it's it's kind of like a visual
thing you know the pawn structure is
intact he has a good night in the center
albeit loose
will it suddenly dawn on him that oh
dear
difficult ferruga is a calculator first
and foremost so he won't be emotional he
won't be thinking am i worse am i
struggling anything like that until he's
done a decent amount of calculation here
he'll be looking how can i defend all my
pawns as black how can i stabilize how
can i get my queen off the same file as
white's rook he'll be looking at all of
that stuff and then if he can't find an
answer then he'll realize uh i think
that he is actually in a bit of trouble
and um i mean going back to that point
about it not being his type of position
foruger from when i've played him from
when i've studied his games he likes to
have three or four different different
moves where he can kind of uh calculate
and try and test his opponent in the all
these different lines
but this is the type of position you
probably have to be really accurate as
black you have to find only moves just
to survive already or just to keep all
of your pawns intact and it's just not
his type of position being on the back
foot and having a really narrow path
to survival so what is that uh only ish
move now then
i mean i'm struggling to find one to be
honest but the only move i i can see
that doesn't lose a pawn immediately is
queen b6
because every i want to get the queen
off the rook i've got a guard of pawn
that's been attacked by the queen i mean
this is the only move i can see but
there's also something a little bit
funny about that move i mean uh i think
it does white can still win a pawn by
moving his rook up the board attacking
this knight which is undefended yeah and
behind it this pawn i mean you mentioned
it simon earlier this pawn is the big
target after all and uh i mean now for
example even if you try and defend your
knight now white's bishop can for
example just attack it kick it out the
way and then this pawn behind it will
drop next i mean there are even ideas of
pushing
this pawn forward and this is quite a
common idea here for example if pawn
takes pawn we'll see that black's rook
is overloaded after a trade of rooks
this night will just drop off
and it's the same you mentioned that
this move maybe for black is
kind of the only way to keep it uh keep
things together for now but it's the
same for example if you sorry if you try
and push your pawn to this square it
looks like you're guarding everything
these pawns defend each other he's
played your move simon but uh again this
pawn push is just gonna capitalize on
the fact that black's pieces are loose
the queen uh is under threat the black
pawn is therefore pinned on the c5
square and if it's pinned you're just
going to capture this pawn most likely
win a pawn it doesn't help that your
knight is loose and also it doesn't look
like much right now but black's king is
actually terribly placed
in the corner there's going to be all
sorts of checkmating ideas against it
and if you have a king like that with no
breathing space not even defending the
rook near it then there's all the
tactics are going to work for white and
there we go prague plays the best move
again without any force at all
and if the knight moves is there is
there some big idea there let's say
only try
i can see um
he has played it i'm wondering if the
white pawn can step forward anyway
right and the whole idea is that after a
capture we will see a rook trade and
then white's rook coming across
to attack
it still goes on maybe the black knight
can try and counter attack against the
white queen um the black queen of course
was attacked here it's a double attack
against the queen and knight one of them
looks like it's dropping but
it's hanging by a thread for black yeah
the valuation is even going up he looks
very very good for white now yeah
he has a lot of experience on the tour
and it's uh looking like he'll get a
good start
in the fdx crypto cup the bars in the
other games have been roughly to the
middle but i think it's slightly over to
a niche geary side in game one against
magnus carlsen very interesting roughly
to the middle between hans niemann and
young christophe duda and also slightly
over to liam le side in his game against
levon ironian it's been a little bit of
a slow start but it's heating up here in
the first round the bar over to prague
side playing fast again yeah he's
playing fast and he's playing the good
moves and we're following into the line
that david mentioned and yeah i wouldn't
say it is a slow and steady opening but
it was very clever against alireza you
know how many moves in 25 moves in
using something very quiet and then
suddenly we see that ali reza is in deep
deep trouble i mean
he's got the psychology yeah perfectly i
mean i don't think he can take that pawn
i mean you can move the rook over
immediately either just this you just
don't see in a bit of taking if you
can't take it you're gonna lose it
and it looks like a clear pawn and you
have a bad position which is
at this level
too much um so
yeah it's worked out perfectly for
prague prague's prank's got everything
he could dream up for the game you can
tell that he studied this in detail i
mean he's found all the right ideas he's
clearly kind of looked at this type of
thing before and also time advantage for
prague that's quite a good start faroush
is renowned as quite a quick player if
furuji gets his type of position he's
just going to be like lightening just
every move coming down on the board
immediately but he's suffering frozen
what a start that would be to his uh to
his tour debut this season yeah
suffering a defeat
it's uh
yeah definitely and one thing i kind of
was asked about recently is like is is
chass
in its kind of death rows you know
because with the advent of computers you
know everyone is playing preparing with
these super computers
you know openings are so difficult to
break down and kind of my answer was
like no because you still have the
psychology element and we saw magnus do
this perfectly against jana pomney
actually towards the end of the world
championship match you know he was
choosing openings to play against the
man to play against the person and here
prague has done it you know this is just
excellent open preparation from the
teenager he's now 17 actually he
celebrated his birthday on um i want to
say i travel on 11th 11th of august
yeah i think it was the 10th 10th yeah
look at that yes it was the 10th it was
the 10th i landed i landed on the 11th
yeah it could have been the temp
somewhere when it was 11th somewhere
right maybe
if you're flying then it could be i
don't know
but by the way he's 17 now and for i
think turned 19 um just before or
uh during the candidates so
these two teenagers still i mean i think
frugia is
having a bit of a slump actually i mean
i i know you mentioned the candidates he
did average but i i think uh
he did actually pretty badly i mean just
just i think maybe this pressure
has got to him um of being tipped as the
next big guy and when the world champion
says or only played a world
championships if this one guy is playing
you've got to be like yeah
that's me i don't know you don't have to
be but it's like it's a lot of pressure
it's suddenly on you and it was very
interesting to see everyone's kind of
preparation for the candidates most
players played tournaments uh forusa
didn't play anything he literally
stopped playing chess
won tournaments in six months exactly
and he hasn't played harley anyway so i
think he's now gonna
get back into proving proving that that
you know he is the man basically again
he's obviously a fantastic player a
brilliant player and it's maybe good
that he's going for a rough period
because it'll make him a better player
in the long run but he he's uh he's up
against it here certainly against uh
young prague
yeah
and well two super teens and look at
that tweet
i love it
not saying david howell is superman but
um we've never seen the two of them
together and i think as i like david
howell
costume or something like that in that
picture a very cool tweet from ryan it's
looking like looking in a mirror yeah
oh cool and look at that we do have the
first result in the ftx crypto cup a
draw in game one between anish giri and
magnus carlsen everyone will start their
games two on top of the hour in uh 23
minutes that is so quite a long break
now for a niche and magnus before magnus
has the white pieces in their game too
leaving the arena together the two
players but this one definitely is still
going on and now the bar is saying more
than two advantage for young prague yeah
prague is doing great and here he can
win a porn in a cup in a couple of
different ways that black pawn that
we've been talking about so much on the
c5 square it could be captured by the
white rook that's under fire in the
center it could also be captured by
white pawn and uh i'm not sure which way
i would be inclined to capture either
way you're going to be a porn up you
just have to decide
you know do you want to connect your
pawns are you happy with an isolated
pawn in the center of the board it will
be a past pawn it's a few different
factors here maybe perhaps just
calculating seeing if he can maximize
his advantage even more right now
what do you guys think i think he's
going to capture with a rook and the
reason i'm saying that is because if i
capture with the pawn then the black
knight is all suddenly on a good circuit
for the preventing the advance of that
pawns but if you capture with the rook
the knight isn't on a great square it
can be destabilized and so that would be
my preference yeah next move you just
kick it away
um you can almost pre-move and uh this
works because the black knight is
actually pinned the black knight cannot
go and capture this pawn because white
will just win a rook and ivanka your
moves on the board and i like that one
as well this one's very tempting just
because now you have a three versus two
advantage long term but why kind of
worry about long-term factors when you
can create immediate threats and because
of this pin feria shuffles his rook out
of the way and
two tempting moves immediately come to
my mind one is just the most obvious
kick away the black knight
and the second one would be to just move
your rook across one square hit the
black queen the rook's defended by a
white bishop and after the queen moves
now you can enter the seventh rank still
a pawn up
maybe this one's less tempting because
the queen and knight might get active
they might start creeping towards this
white king i don't think they're
creating any threats to be honest but
yeah maybe you don't want to allow
anything any counterplay any glimmer of
hope at all
so current position is this one
are we going to have a vote pawn forward
maybe come forward rook across
um
yeah i like pushing pawns so uh you know
why not you know attack a piece push
pawn one square near a queening so
yeah it looks it looks logical doesn't
it to push that one so i guess if the
black knight jumps into the center
there's a couple of squares but if it
jumps into the center it can just get
kicked around okay we do see this and
okay the knight here would be unstable
the white queen for example could come
and attack it soon instead farouza moves
his knight to this square
and again plenty of choice you can move
your rook across again you can just
centralize your queen slightly
so many choices and uh yeah just a clear
pawn up
the only thing you have to really be
careful of here is that the knight
doesn't jump in and start checking your
king anytime soon but for now the white
queen covers this square covers all the
squares white's bishop can often
dominate a black knight for example if
the bishop kind of sits on this square
the black knight won't always be
controlled
so uh lots of choice and
for now and decent amount of time
in big trouble prague should convert
this
it's strange because the evaluation bar
obviously gives it as what 2.7 i think
but pawn is like one right so he
actually
really thinks that white's nearly three
pawns up which i'm trying to work out i
think that's quite a high evaluation it
doesn't i mean it's obviously a clear
pawn and white's doing very well but to
be that much up over a pawn is is quite
intriguing uh there's a number of ways
white can play this as you said david i
mean you could just you could play it
slowly if you if you wanted to and you
know just roll that pawn down a little
bit later on uh you have to be a bit bit
careful i suppose if black can blockade
the pawn uh when you're playing against
the past pawn if you can get your knight
in front of that pawn that's a brilliant
blockader so if you can just imagine the
black knight moving in front of the
white pawn which it can't do at the
moment because it can't get on that
route but if it ever can do that then
black could get a blockade and it'd be
quite hard to break down uh just worth
thinking about these small things when
you're you're trying to sort of looking
at your opponent's pawns and how to deal
with them um but
he he can't do that easily at all here
so um so i'm i'm not sure
um would he play in
white stoner very just centralizing his
queen there very sensible yeah
controlling a lot of squares and black
defense the night with his rook and yeah
it's interesting what you mentioned
there simon the evaluation bar because
you're right if this was a blitz game
which it pretty much is now both players
down to around three minutes if it was a
blitz game i would just think okay i'm a
pawn down i've still got practical
chances i've got a knight and a queen
together they're really tricky great
attacking combo i'll trick swindle my
opponent later but uh evaluation bar
thinks it's just gone oh it's incredible
isn't it actually i'm just like why you
know why why computer you're always
confusing me
um i mean i can understand like one and
a half pawns maybe or two even but i
don't know yeah so but and i i raised
now playing much quicker right i mean he
he realizes he's he's losing this so
he's doing a very good practical thing
and this was actually in that book chest
for tigers which we've all got right
right we've all got chess for tigers
that sounds like a good book
first my first reaction was this this
was another chess of fishing right now
tigers is an actual book of course it is
i would never dream of tricking you
ever in a million years
have i gotten back to you yet i don't
think i have no no you don't want to do
that you don't want to do that
but what is chess for tigers this is
something uh vishy and isn't he the
tiger from madras yeah it was a book
written by i think simon webb yeah and
um it is one of my favorite books it's
really uh just a funny read as well so
it's got a bit of humor in there and
it's about like practical ways to play
chess so how you should play if you've
got a losing position um how you should
play if you've got a winning position so
just like you know it gives you very
good not just about moves it's a really
fun read and one of the things i
remember in that book was that when
you've got a losing position as alireza
has here that's kind of the only time
you can speed up and try to win on time
don't do that unless your position is
bad because why would you but then you
can try you know you want to try to
hustle more when you've got a bad
position and talking about hustling this
is the type of hustle move that uh
happens you know
yeah you know ultimately it's probably
not a good move but it does carry some
ghosts and the ghosts could freak out uh
pragnanda for starters that black pawn
could push one square further just start
destabilizing the white king
and uh
well
pragananda is like no i'm not phased by
that this is the perfect strategy
and says come at me it's just the pawn
it's so tough to play against these
players who calculate everything and who
are so realistic
and uh don't get abs and don't get
flummoxed at all yeah he's ice cored
pregnant i've learned that from playing
against him it's very hard to
kind of get under his skin uh just to
make him sweat yeah he just
cold-bloodedly calculates everything and
i think the best reaction if your
opponent does try to just throw pawns at
you throw pieces at you if you can
calculate everything if you see you've
got things under control just stick to
your plans just uh don't kind of start
reacting don't start going onto the back
foot just uh for the sake of it and yeah
black's pawn move pushing the h-pawn
it's the typical motif nowadays but it's
not actually doing anything in this
specific scenario so white's rook on the
seventh franc eyeing up a couple of
pawns
for rougea i mean he slowed down again
it's as if he's trying to get some
kind of energy going but prague is just
shutting the door
every single time i just love what
white's done all of the rooks
and the white queen they're all
protecting each other white stacked up
on the sea file the white pawn in the
center of the board blockades
kind of blocks all of black's army
i also like the fact that he just pushed
a pawn near the white king earlier
white's h pawn the black knight now
cannot creep into white's half of the
board
he's just he's trying to play for
control for domination and it's
succeeding so far foreign down to one
minute just
unable to find any kind of idea right
now yeah this is a problem and there's
really not that much he can do he
doesn't really want to be curling up
into a ball because of course pragnanda
is material up and he's gone he's gone
for the defensive
this is a bad sign i thought maybe he
would just abandon
this uh throw caution to the wind and
give him even more material just to
generate some play but
okay well maybe maybe there's still hope
for for rooja
yeah maybe it's all about that blockade
that simon mentioned earlier so um
ideally a black knight would be
blockading white's past porn in the
center but now it's the black queen
queens are actually not good blockaders
in general but at least white's porn
can't go anywhere yet
so big question is do you trade queens
do you get rid of that blockade the
black queen
or do you just
sit on black just say okay you're not
doing anything you're having to play
passive moves like bring the black rook
to a bad square do you just shuffle okay
he does try and trade the queens by
force
if the queens disappear though white's
pawn structure is slightly compromised
yeah i kind of like that move though
because i suppose you know the only way
that black could have got counterplay
was by using the h pawn pushing it one
square creating some opportunities even
though they're very small opportunities
they're still a little bit annoying
get rid of the queens get rid of the
danger it's kind of the the terminology
you know when you swap the queens off
you swap the danger off so um of course
added razer does not want to swap the
queens off even if it did damage white
structure it was pretty grim ending that
one so he keeps the queens on him just
to show simon you're right i mean it's
it's minimal damage here okay it's
doubled pawns but the big factor is that
white has the active rooks uh this rook
especially and now no more blockade of
this past pawn so this would have been
winning
uh it might have taken a while but this
would have been winning long term for
prague instead for ruja he's he's kind
of seizing the wisdom from chest for
tigers he's just keeping
the pieces on the board playing quickly
if he can
at least now he's hinting that the queen
is on the same diagonal as the white
king there's no real threats yet but if
the queen can combine somehow with a
black knight the big question again for
prague is how to keep control how to
progress your advantage
if i had
a lot of time on the clock here if i was
playing a long game a classical game i
would maybe calculate pushing this pawn
forward and he hasn't played it of
course
i need a lot of time david i was about
to say if i only had one minute maybe i
would just play a non-committal move
just maybe improve a rook or something
but nope he's going for the win
advantage and two squares away now from
promotion also the white bishop look how
it's opened up on this diagonal it was
blocked previously by its own pawn now
no longer so even if this pawn drops
white is probably doing very well
because white's bishop is uh more potent
the black knight yeah and okay queen in
the center makes a lot of sense these
look pretty good now but
how long will it last
queen swap off yeah insisting on the
trade clinical stuff from pregnant here
um i mean that's just perfect and the d
pawn looks very dangerous doesn't it you
think as well so yeah
the white pawn is going to step forward
it has come at the cost of uh this pawn
however black's queen getting greedy
grabbing a pawn i don't know how
relevant that is to be honest for
example white's porn can step forward
now it looks like you're about to make a
new queen or at least you'll win one of
black's pieces uh in return for this
very strong pawn but is that even better
what is prague gonna calculate i mean
he'll be looking at all sorts of things
the one thing he has to worry about is a
night fork then black knight is
threatening to jump in hitting the white
queen and hitting this rook
so one threat well i think if you do
that you might get checkmated actually
today because there's oh wait that
horrible queen swinger isn't it right
simon you might even better force that
knight away here oh wow in the current
position yeah possibly
i didn't even see this but this is the
type of thing prague will spot if the
knight is hit even if it does jump
forward with this fork remember then
simon you you spotted it queen takes
pawn now he regrets pushing his uh harry
point forward check and wow every move
so perfect so accurate by prague it's a
check and uh okay another pawn will drop
and eventually the black king
will perish this is just game over this
push prague is going to win it's almost
guaranteed at this point
yeah
it was under 20 seconds and it's ticking
down and there's just no hope for
survival for ferugia he retreats his
knight and knight is the king's best
defender but futile stuff here
tantamount to resignation here the black
king has moved across but i mean for
example the white bishop can come into
the center threatening stuff along this
diagonal black has one check but it's
just one check i think the white king
can just hide safely in the corner
i mean this is uh maybe not the safest
way of doing it but this would end the
game what else could you try you could
try pushing this pawn forward
you could just centralize the white
queen if you just want to cover any
checks from the black queen
spoil for choice now prague and okay the
most direct
he's always playing the most direct
doesn't i mean even though
to me that move looks like oh the white
king's a bit airy
i might not play that because i can
probably keep it safer but it's just
pure calculation and and the bet you
know the most dynamic moves and it's a
killer and uh very impressive game by
prague very impressive i mean uh he's
been in control very clever opening and
uh i can't you know i don't think
there's any way back now for alireza he
has to play this horrible looking move
here look at these two black rooks
they're so passive stuck just defending
pawns
i mean here a really sadistic move that
i would be tempted by as prague is just
shuffle the white king in the corner no
more checks on a light square can't get
attacked and then you just kind of laugh
you're threatening here queen takes
knight because of a pin here the black
pawn is not really defending that black
knight if you play immediately at least
black has a check and we'll win this
bishop next so you don't want to take
that knight yet okay of course he plays
it
and uh yeah the white king now
no more ghosts to worry about and even
though black queen can come back and
defend you can push this pawn you can
just
i mean there must be plenty of winning
moves here
looks like he's just putting the
finishing touches on a great game
what a fantastic start for young
pragnanda a very long game this one
played for fifth well okay they started
10 minutes late i forgot so actually it
only lasted 42 minutes
so far this game and that they will have
a 10 minute break after this game to get
ready for their game to remember best
out of four rapid games in each match
this is only game one but it looks like
pregnant will take the lead and that
means for russia he has to make a
comeback at some point if they are tied
after four games then we head straight
to tie breaks with blitz and potentially
armageddon chess on tsar we will see
some blitz chess every day and some more
moves on the board some more moves and
uh prague's still in full control he
brings his queen across now i mean he's
only one pawn up actually in the
position but he's a pretty big pawn that
white d-pawn just immobilizes all of
black's army
and okay this is a fishing expedition
for ferozia the black queen just
attacking one pawn here maybe one pawn
across on the third rank as well but
um shouldn't be enough at least he's
maybe putting some
uh well at least making pregnant back
pedal slightly the white queen the white
king stepping forward now
there we go there has been a result
between duda yeah look at that and we
see some technical stuff going on a
massive win for hans niemann against
young christoph duda
i know this guy he's a technical guy
something happened if you look at the
board david something must have happened
because the position looks very balanced
it looks roughly level so
i'm not sure the result is correct i'm
not sure neiman has actually won maybe
something happened and dude has clocked
it down to zero but
either way there has been some drama
neither player looks like they're ready
to leave they may be assuming the game
will continue
first day nerves yeah thursday problems
yeah and uh talking about continuing
this game is over pragnanda has won he's
beaten alireza wow what a start for now
17 year old frag
winning game one against uh
the what the best junior in the world
ali reza for is a bad start for him